13 et construisirent est un truc
construction permanente ces noms de code
pour traite excusez moi mais moi je le
conçois comme ça alors constructif c'est
le nom de code pour trait comme pour
traite voilà qu'elle mérite de la clarté
yves thréard sait et c'est aussi votre
avis
écoutez je sais pas si c'est mon avis il
simplement que c'est un sujet qui
n'intéresse personne n'a pas cassé
sincèrement sincèrement parce que
capable et le sujet quel est le sujet
beaucoup de français se disent mais
attendez ils sont pas d'accord ils sont
plus d'accord avec les républicains mais
pourquoi ils sont pas partis de leur
propre chef
dès le début et pourquoi ils sont pas
partis de leur propre chef dès le début
parce que justement ils veulent ennuyé
lors leur ancien parti parce que ils
veulent les pousser à prononcer
l'exclusion et chacun sait que
l'exclusion c'est peut-être très
impopulaire en tous les cas dans
l'esprit de beaucoup de beaucoup de
français
sincèrement ce que veulent les électeurs
et notamment les électeurs de droite
c'est que les choses soient claires je
pense que pour une majorité d'entre eux
ils sont pour que les constructif
quittent le navire de la rue de
vaugirard et que et bien les
républicains se reconstruise évidemment
sans les constructif qui ne seront rien
d'ailleurs
or les républicains puisque de toute
manière macron n'a pas besoin de dons
qu'ils peuvent très bien créer leur
parti
ça ne gênera à mon avis personne